some signatures on mail ballots still
need to be confirmed before those votes
can be counted the i-team's vanessa
murphy has more on the status
of signature verification vanessa
brian it's a small percentage of voters
who have to go through the process to
confirm
their signatures it's also known as
signature curing
and here's information from the
secretary of state's website
more about the numbers made publicly
available now
here's how the process works the mail
ballot is scanned in a machine to make
sure the signature matches what is on
file
either from voter registration a
previous ballot the voter signed or even
a driver's license
there have to be multiple and
significant differences in order for the
signature to be
rejected then at least two election
workers review the signature
if they believe the signature cannot be
verified they must reach out to the
voter to give them a chance to confirm
the signature is theirs
they can use an app through the
secretary of state's office or answer
personal questions
through the registrar's office and if
that happens the signature is then
cured and the ballot is counted here's
what deputy secretary of state wayne
thorley told me
we'll wednesday be waiting on some of
these cures to come in so it's a very
drawn out process and we tried to
prepare
voters and the public and candidates for
that after the passage of assembly bill
4
that look election results are going to
take much longer
than usual to become final and it's
simply because of these extra processes
the legislature put in place
now voters have until november 12th to
cure their ballots in a lawsuit
filed by nevada republicans and a voter
which i-team reporter david charns will
talk more about coming up
they argue the resolution clark county
is using for signature verification
is not good enough and the latest
numbers from the secretary of state's
office as i mentioned are right here so
right now as of this evening the total
ballots needing signature cures for
clark county
more than 6 000 the total successful
cures so far about 4 500
the total ballots still needing cures
more than 1500 so going back here it's
just 1.46 percent
again just to show you it's a very small
number
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now
that really helped